commerces fermés locaux à l'abandon ces
dernières années les vitrines vides se
sont multipliés dans le centre ville de
nevers une perte d'attractivité et un
spectacle devenue intolérable pour le mr
ouai c'est le type de restaurant qui est
fermé depuis un certain nombre d'années
et dans le cadre de sa politique
volontariste de redynamisation du
commerce de centre ville on a voulu
effectivement incité et le but ce n'est
pas de pénaliser il faut faire réagir
les propriétaires donc j'étais dans la
citation en deux ans aujourd'hui c'est
de dire voilà ceux qui n'appliquent pas
des prix corrects au prix du marché et
seront pénalisés sur leur taxe foncière
huit commerces ou sites ont été ciblés
leurs propriétaires verront leur taxe
foncière majorée de 20%
le but oreillers une hausse continue
depuis 2010 des friches commerciales à
nevers 26% des commerces sont vacants
actuellement si on fait des comparatifs
entre 2010 et 2016
nous avions des rues où tous les
commerces étaient occupés et on a
maintenant des rues notamment la rue
saint martin ou l'avenue du général de
gaulle qui ont vu doubler voire tripler
le nombre de commerces fermaient
boutique supermarché ancienne maison de
l'agriculture les friches sont multiples
tout comme leur cause changement des
habitudes des consommateurs loyers
élevés locaux inadaptés
la taxe est donc un aspect d'un plan
d'action que les commerçants espèrent
plus vaste pour mettre en place des
outils et des éléments pour pour revenir
dans les clous quoi et ça la taxation
locaux vacants rentrer dans une
politique beaucoup plus globale aux
signes de redynamisation du centre-ville
la nouvelle taxe entrera en vigueur au
mois de janvier la liste des friches
concernés sera actualisée chaque année
pour tenir compte des efforts des
propriétaires